bonjour jean eric branaa merci d'être
avec nous quand on dit et s'il gagne
encore c'est donald trump a évidemment
justement qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre
du discours de donald trump eric bana
peut attendre quelque chose de très
volontaire puisque donald trump va
surtout parler assez à ses supporters va
par les futurs électeurs il a les
élections en ligne de mire puisqu'on est
à 42 jours de l'élection présidentielle
américaine et qu'en réalité on a déjà
commencé à voter dans pas mal d'états
donc tout ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui bien
sûr à cette couleur électorale
maintenant sur la dimension
internationale il faut quand même
attendre le renouvellement du postulat
très bon à savoir que c'est l'amérique
qui compte avant tout et que le reste du
monde doit se plier cette volonté
américaine c'est pas un postulat
uniquement travis l'instant un postulat
américain de base quelles que soient les
présidents mais c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus marquée avec donald trump
parce que la rhétorique est un peu plus
forte la voit donc porte non plus séduit
il agit souvent une façon qui fait qu'on
n'attend pas comme ce week-end avec de
nouvelles sanctions qui ont été imposées
à l'iran au nom de nos études ailleurs
alors que lui n'est qu'un membre de
l'onu même si les états unis sont le
principal contributeur de cette
organisation et et c'est ça qui va
renouveler aujourd'hui ce qui a été
annoncé donc hier et la semaine dernière
ses sanctions à l'iran est le fait que
les alliés entre guillemets la france la
grande bretagne l'allemagne doivent
suivre les deux pas de la mairie
sinon il y aurait effectivement roya tus
jean eric branaa pour l'instant c'est
antonio guterres s inquiète à la tribune
qui est en train de s'exprimer on la vit
ensuite il va y avoir d'ailleurs bolson
arrow qui après ce sera au tour de
donald trump
mais hier on attendait donald trump ans
était
tout simplement le discours anniversaire
pour fêter les 75 ans de l'onu est-ce
qu'il va s'exprimer
donald trump à ce que finalement hier
c'est sa représentante qui a parlé à sa
place son conseiller spécial marc
meadows lui a déclaré aux journalistes
récemment à bord d'air force one que
donald trump finalement ne se rendra pas
à l'assemblée générale de l'onu
mais il s'agit d'un discours un par
visioconférence il devrait être diffusé
dans tout à l'heure sur et nous oui oui
bien sûr il va parler mais hier il a
fait très fort quand même parce que ce
n'est même pas la diplomate en chef mais
là la seconde diplomates envoyés états
unis dont je me souviens plus du nom
c'est pour dire si elle est vraiment
obscures par rapport à normalement
l'ambassadrice à l'onu pour pour les
états unis n'hésitez pas à effectuer sa
donc c'était encore plus loin sa montre
et le peu de cas que donald trump fait
de cette organisation puisque
effectivement on avait reculé dans
l'organigramme et que c'était pas très
important c'était toujours la voix de
l'amérique même si elle était portée par
quelqu'un d'autre
mais aujourd'hui bien sûr de la halle
tram va s'exprimer puisque là on est
dans une moment à qui le clae avec 7
cette attaque frontale la l'organisation
elle-même au pouvoir de cette
organisation et puis aux rapports avec
l'europe puisque c'est ça qui est en jeu
à travers cette question iranienne
la question iranienne est très important
dans le contexte électoral américain
puisqu'il s'agit de montrer avec la
chine
donald trump ne lâche absolument pas les
deux gros morceaux qui ont fait sa
politique étrangère pendant ces 4 en mai
mais il faudra encore une fois il prend
à rebours les européens et et on se
souvient que dès la première fois les
entreprises françaises autres
européennes ont plié aux inventions de
donald trump de faire du commerce avec
l'iran
là les entreprises ont plié de la même
façon parce que tout le monde a en tête
c'est ces amendes et des normes qui ont
été apposées à la qualité donnée à la
bnp de talent donc c'est c'est la
puissance
week-end de façon reste du monde
justement l'onu c'est le
multilatéralisme donald trump lui c'est
le chantre de l'unilatéralisme
en quoi cette session qui va durer toute
la semaine
comme comme chaque année en quoi est ce
qu'elle peut renouer les liens entre les
deux sachant que cette année il n'y aura
pas de discussions de couloir
coronavirus oblige on sait que souvent
c'est dans les discussions de couloir
dans les dans les petites salles annexes
à l'onu ou même dans l'hôtel qui jouxte
le bâtiment de l'onu que les grandes
décisions sont prises
là cette année il y aura pas ça
puisqu'il n'ya que deco visioconférence
essais virtuels
bah écoutez moi je trouve que les
circonstances sont quand même étonnant
parce que la pandémie
effectivement à geler toutes les
discussions et 7,7 grand chambardement
entre multilatéralisme médical
atterrissent de cette année on a pas
mais c'est un moment aussi où sur le
plan électoral et par intérieur
américain on a aussi ce choc avec un
bail donne qui est lui multilatéraliste
et et un treuil qui est unilatéraliste
quoique ayant dit ça encore une fois
bind est un multilatéraliste mais avec
prépondérance américaine il avait dit
d'ailleurs après le 11 septembre
pardon après la chute du mur berlin très
bonne nouvelle nous sommes la première
puissance au monde
les très mauvaises nouvelles nous sommes
la seule puissance au monde et c'est
vraiment comme ça qu'ils vivent les
américains dont il ya toujours cette
idée que n'importe comment cette
organisation est plutôt une organisation
de gêneurs puisque elle vient faire la
leçon aux américains qui veut être
maître de leur destin
et puis qui explique que le sens de
cette organisation n'existe pas ce qui
n'est pas faux le rappelons que le
budget total de lloret nulle part dont
deux lettres de l'amérique la
contribution est de 22% budget total et
pour les actions de maintien de paix
salon de même le je crois bien de tête à
28 5% ce qui l'amène à 7 milliards de
dollars donc ça ne s'est pas remis des
sommes énormes et sans la puissance
américaine effectivement l'ol ne pouvait
pas faire grand chose dans le monde
merci jean eric branaa d'avoir répondu à
une question des prix fera avec vous
tout à l'heure le discours de donald
trump aux nations unies je rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste des états unis et
auteur notamment du livre
et s'il gagnait encore aux éditions weka
presse à tout à l'heure donc